the juror experience
but what i was saying is like i was also
interested in people that have
dispositional attentional challenges
like right adhd what is that is that
real adhd 100
attention functions on a continuum right
so
i mean i'd love to tell you about let me
tell you about attention because that
kind of makes me feel like at least
we'll be on the same page then as it
relates to
uh what i'm talking about because even
the mindfulness stuff is related to
attention so
attention usually in the way we've been
talking about it we've been talking
about it is focus right so
what does that mean to you right now
you're laser focused on me you've got
awesome
attention at least it looks that way
focusing on me everything else is kind
of fuzzed out
and that we call um
the brain's orienting system so i i
think of it like a flashlight so
wherever it is that you direct your
attention in that way you're privileging
that content so right now you're seeing
my face with more granularity hearing my
voice with the crispness more than the
air conditioner or
whatever jamie might be saying you know
like right now you're focused in on on
on me thank you very much so
that
that actually
does neurally look like it enhances the
sensory input if you focus in on my
voice your
neurons as early as your auditory cortex
within a few hundred milliseconds you're
going to have a
clearer
comprehension but even just auditory
input's going to be amplified as a
function of of paying attention
and you know just like literally a
flashlight if you're in a darkened space
you know you value that thing you
wherever it is that it points it
actually gives you that privileged
information the cool thing about the
flashlight is you can direct it
willfully you can point it
you can also not just direct it to the
external environment i can say like
right now joe like what's the
what's the sensations on the bottoms of
your feet
can you can you sense into that were you
thinking about before i said it no it
wasn't flashlight got directed to
internal bodily sensations you can pick
that up so it actually goes to one of
the reasons attention even evolved in
our brain we talked about the evolution
of distractibility which was to
advantage our survival but why do we
have attention in the first place why do
we even develop this capacity to focus
and it comes down to the brain had a big
problem
which is that there's far more
information in the environment than it
could possibly process so it's got a sub
sample it's got to like
get bits and pieces of what's going on
and attention just like the flashlight
you know if you were in a darkened room
you kind of figure out the landscape you
kind of scan it and kind of put together
the image
same idea with attention focus very
important
we can talk about this but i actually
want to tell you about the other two
main systems but just keep in mind that
not only can we direct the flashlight
but it can get yanked
so if you're in a darkened room and you
hear a weird sound you're going to point
to wherever the sound came from so
that's the double-edged sword of this
system is that it's not just about where
it goes again very good reasons that we
evolved to have that
have you ever done any personal
experimentation with sensory deprivation
tanks oh i want to i definitely want to
talk to you about that and actually i
think that i have not i want to oh you
have to i want to um i just haven't had
a chance to go
so i will definitely i definitely want
to but it actually perfect segue into
the second system of attention
which is the exact opposite of this
narrowing and privileging
and the second big system of attention i
use the the metaphor of like a
floodlight it's called the alerting
system
the floodlight unlike the flashlight is
narrow privileging some information on
the other floodlight broad
receptive
no privileging of any information allows
whatever comes up to come up the only
thing that's privileging is the now
like what's important right now and i
always when i'm driving i think about
this often you see a flashing yellow
light probably near a construction site
or near school maybe what does that mean
pay attention
but it's not like that narrow focus
attention like broad receptive something
weird may happen be ready for it
so
this is like i said it's the this
this system
is so important and probably and not
just probably i mean there's a lot of
evidence that suggests
in things like sensory deprivation
you now are challenging that system
because what is happening is not
necessarily from the actual environment
so whatever is the
baseline existence within the internal
milieu
may actually be more salient to you
because just like the flashlight where
you can direct it internally externally
or internally the floodlight you can
also direct externally and internally
so in the opposite absence of sensory
input
you're kind of in this receptive state
where everything that's occurring
internally there's an acute and rich
awareness of that um anyway so you got
flashlight floodlight and then the third
system
is b we call it executive control it's
tied to this notion of the whiteboard
and working memory it's essentially the
manager
it's like
just like the flashlight is selecting
based on content you know light right
side or left side the flood light is is
selecting based on time what's important
right now
this system is selecting information
because the whole goal of attention is
to subsample reality you just have
different slices does that making sense
the third system executive control is is
sub sampling based on your goals
so what is what most goal relevant right
now that should guide the way that i
perceive and act so this system's job
and the term executive is like the way
we talk about executives of a company
the executive's job is not to go in and
do every single task but it's to ensure
that the goals of the organization and
the behavior of the organization align
and then when it's a mess up the
executive says no fix that
so this is where things like maintaining
the goal working memory that's where we
put our goals when we maintain them
inhibiting irrelevant information it's
like
you know no you don't need to go think
about that right now right like even in
the even in the context of a sensory
deprivation tank it's like yeah that's
great i probably should remember that
but i can't not experience this right
now it's like goal was experience
sensory deprivation not go write
something so inhibit urges we might have
or behaviors we might have
update new information update your goal
and even shift like you are on that goal
but get on that goal so very complex
system i like to think of it as like a
juggler as just like all the balls are
in the air but it's a manager it really
is doing this so the reason i wanted to
tell you that is because
you know attention is such a topical
thing like people always say their
problems are with attention and you were
asking me about add and is it real
yes it ends up that we have people
differ along their set points of all
three of these systems
and oftentimes we see people that
not only are
are
problematic on any one system like
they're too focused it's a dysregulation
so either hyper focus you can't get the
flashlight off
or you're hyper vigilant you can't stop
seeing everything is requiring this
broad receptive almost um
anxiety provoking level of of um
of
present moment awareness
or you just can't keep the balls in the
air there's a problem with your with
your juggler so for sure people vary
along these lines and sometimes they
vary in their coordination because these
none of these systems work alone you
know the the
executive control is telling the
flashlight where to go
the the um
alerting system is telling you what's
going on so you need to know if you need
so there's this constant fluidity
between these things
so sometimes it's the coordination that
gets messed up and when people's lives
are
negatively impacted by the way their
attention functions
to the point where it's actually causing
serious problems that's when sometimes
it gets diagnosed as add you know even
before we talk about thinking what we
don't do for any of us it's very very
rare
is teach people the value and importance
of checking out where their mind is
moment by moment and going back to the
people with add the patients that have
add diagnosable edd their pro their life
is problematic because of this
set of set points they have on all these
three systems of attention
those that have this thing we're talking
about which the technical term is meta
awareness it's essentially a version of
that
floodlight that i was talking about
broad receptive but you're checking out
technically meta awareness is
having awareness of
the current contents and processes of
your mind
moment by moment
so first of all to say oh yeah i can do
that i i can see and we do this all the
time we say oh yeah look i'm really you
were you just did it a moment ago my
brain's not working right now like
you're checking in and you're saying
right now it's not the crispness i want
there to be but you're attuned to it
and so it may make you do something
differently because you're aware of it
if we're not even aware of where our
mind is
there's not a lot of opportunity that we
can do anything about it so it ends up
if you look at people with add that have
a lot of problems their minds wander a
lot meaning they have off-task thoughts
a lot but they also happen to have good
meta-awareness their lives don't their
lives don't suffer all that much
meaning they can they can
have a job and do things that are kind
of normal kinds of things
so do you think we're doing a disservice
by medicating people when they have that
instead of by training them how to focus
you know this is exactly where i'm going
so that was a question i thought was a
legitimate thing to ask
we didn't want to start out by saying
stop your medication so i involved we
one of the studies we did in my lab is
that we
um
recruited a bunch of people adults with
add
and we said just keep on your regular
meditation what is the what what's the
like
what's the average medication like what
are they on for the most part did you
ask them i mean all kinds of things
whether it's strotero welbutin bulbutrin
or
adiron
those are
ssris though right there's some there's
combinations
an ssri
i'm not that's not my neuro neuro a
pharmacology is not my thing you can
look it up yeah
but the point is that we said whatever
your particular medication cocktail is
stay on it now take this eight week
mindfulness training program and that
program was like we started with a
minute of practice very active practices
so now it's not sit quietly and focus on
your breath it's go for a walk feel the
sensations of your feet on the ground
when your mind wanders come back so we
we worked up to about 12 minutes a day
for these adults with add and then at
the end of the ex
training program
we said
you know we looked at the objective
metrics looking better less mind
wandering for the people that did the
practices
but but when i just inquired what's
different about
your medication use or your mind they'd
say
before i used to take my ritalin and
then
play video games for eight hours and i
did really awesome on the video games
but i didn't finish my homework or i
forgot to go to work you know like
they had this raw power to focus in some
sense with some of the medications but
they didn't have the meta awareness to
know if they were using it correctly
after the training that was the number
one most consistent thing people said i
was aware of where my mind was i could
use my time better because i was
checking in where am i right now oh is
that tied to where i want to be let me
redirect
that's also the thing that
all of us benefit from with with
mindfulness training is that
not only does it connect to
using the flashlight
it allows us to cultivate that kind of
broad receptive stance
toward what is unfolding right now so
that
the executive control system can update
shift or redirect when things are off
track that makes the whole thing
function better watch the entire episode
for free only on spotify